it's a great question number one I was a
Democratic caucus at Mendel caucus no
you haven't you're a lying dog face
pony-soldiers you said you are but now
you gotta be honest I'm gonna be honest
with you there is breathing heavily into
the microphone the man the geniuses in
Washington picked to protect the
Democratic Party from the great
socialist threat babbling about John
Wayne movies that don't even exist after
him they're putting all their hopes into
two tiny mayor's propped up by immense
piles of cash it's hilarious if nothing
else joining us tonight to make sense of
it is our friend author and columnist
mark Stein
look what is happening well actually
just first of all Tucker that I don't
think it is a John Wayne movie I think
he's referring to a movie called pony
soldier in which Tyrone Power played a
Mountie up in Canada exactly right yeah
1952 so I don't know whether he just got
confused here we we call on the
Democrats we look to them to speak truth
to power Joe Biden was speaking truth to
Tyrone Power admittedly almost almost 70
years after he made the movie but better
late than never
this is only a surprise everyone know I
think I said it on your show that Joe
Biden was at his strongest the day
announced and it's all been downhill and
it's sad to see that while the pitiful
group of my fellow Granite Staters
singing Joe Biden's back I've got no
problems with Joe Biden's back the
problem is Joe Biden's front when you
look at him when you look at his face
when you look at his mouth it's clear
that his heart isn't in this and that
was obvious from you can't have legacy
candidates they tried that four years
ago and now they're stuck in the in the
worst of all worlds they need someone oh
there we go Joe Biden's back it's you
know if you want a good back song my
boyfriend's back by the Angels but
number number number
37 in 1961 that's the one do you forget
Joe Biden's back now I'm all distracted
by Joe I don't want to think about Joe
Biden's back they've got the same
problem that the Republicans had four
years ago who can take out Bernie and
none of these guys can take out Bernie
and my only disagreement with what you
said Tucker was when you mentioned Amy
Klobuchar and we all dismiss her as the
sensible shoes candidate and all the
rest of it but on that stage when they
were asked who which of them would have
a problem with a socialist candidate in
other words they're actually being asked
which of you guys is ready to take out
Bernie the only one who said she did
have a problem with the socialist
candidate was in fact Amy Klobuchar and
I generally take the view that who dares
wins here and she was the only one on
that stage to actually show any courage
isn't it I think you know that their
reflexes too and I think if that's a
very smart point their reflex though is
to go right to the billionaire you know
they've got a problem and they the
billionaires gonna save them from the
problem I mean what does that tell you
about them well I think that they're
different from the Republicans the
Republicans wanted to get rid of Trump
and couldn't find a way to do so
honestly right now on the Democrat side
we're having serial malodorous nests
we're starting from the the Iowa poll
that wasn't released then the Iowa
caucus that's right now whoever wind as
the joke has it whoever wins New
Hampshire that will give them a lot of
momentum going into the Iowa caucus
results which might well be recaulk as'
so they they they interfered in that now
they're trying to interfere by bringing
back super-delegates by putting the
billionaire on the stage all these are
sticks of dynamite that the Yosemite
Sam's of the Democrats and the media
keep shoving down their pants and they
and each one of them so far starting
with impeachment has actually blown up
in their faces that's when they still
keep shoveling the dynamite down their
pants and it just couldn't happen to
better people it's really it's no no's
made my day
every day marks not great to see you
thank you thanks a lot Tucker